[Musica]
sena appendete
vecchio the jacket
al divino banche
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi penserete che sono matto
ancora non siamo arrivati a quel livello
quello che vedete dietro di me è il set
del nuovo calendario dell'avvento che
andremo a creare insieme a tutto quanto
il cui buste ma lo scorso anno insieme
alla famiglia e tutti quanti parenti
abbiamo creato un calendario
dell'avvento in collaborazione con cech
è andato da dio sold out tutti quanti
che facevamo i pastori del presepe gesù
maria giuseppe il bue l'asinello
qualsiasi cosa visto che il gustin per
me è veramente una seconda famiglia
abbiamo deciso di creare uno shooting un
pochino diverso il classico sogno del
natale americano per cui ognuno di noi
avrà dei ruoli li scoprirete tra poco ma
soprattutto quest'anno staremo sopra un
calendario diverso con l'anno scorso
mentre l'anno scorso abbiamo usato
quella da kinder cosa che faremo anche
quest'anno che si sa mai il prince e
magna abbiamo deciso di prendere anche
quello da riempire ma scoprirete che
cosa ci metteremo dentro solamente più
avanti direi di partire subito col video
e andare a scoprire soprattutto da che
cosa si stanno travestendo tutte quante
le persone io sono stato il più
fortunato vi dico solo questo
[Musica]
questo è il primo capitolo giusto babbo
natale tu eri già ma per natale ho
portato dei doni no
[Risate]
enrico ad i panni sporchi nella pancia
verso vomitare 100 100 chiude a casa per
natale
maggior bisogno di voi siete già
annunciati biscottini voi no io si è
fatto
di pallini maligna ieri abiti biscottini
dalle pareti vivamente che a
federico
gandolfi
esattori
natali stazione italia
parlano
e sporco di sugo per sorrentino
ma cosa è sicura sia sugo
scoppiando di caldo quanto tutto il
mondo puoi accomodarti sul divano
intanto però c'è rimangono
[Musica]
ma che abbiamo qui
adesso al lavoro schiava è stato già
tutto fatto ai legali sono pronti io
sono qui per i biscotti alla ventura che
bene ha
[Musica]
fatto il rito per
i sei tu
56 delfo cattivo giusto ben diversi dal
mega prima
guarda che se veramente o tu sei la
causa del fatto che i bambini non
credono più in me vengo le vedono sempre
il padre di famiglia che mangia biscotti
allora sei tu che manti biscotti non è
babbo natale
[Musica]
pronto polizia potete venire a rendere
bene per favore io non so che più
normale sentano per rotte vecchio gran
parlare al telefono grazie sopporto
cazzo [ __ ] graziano guglielmo
tu chi sei
io sono il figlio di guglielmo ancora il
conto non merita l'editore non hanno
però insomma c'è nel senso non si nota
vabbè il momento abbiamo pensato che
predator potesse andare bene come
bambino di un anno allora che cosa
possesso al mese fa benissimo è proprio
il figlio che desiderano
[Risate]
[Musica]
la mamma di famiglia bambini venire per
favore io voglio presentarvi dirmi
quello stato anche rino marinella a 5
anni e il mio bambino per di magro due
anni preda torino rino
[Risate]
grazie caro anche tu sei bellissima come
doveva tutti i bigodini e li ha fatti
grazie notari stata capace di farla
l'acconciatura anni 50 una bellissima no
no no no non ci credo
è finito biscotti
cercare caro
ricordo ancora il giorno in cui riuscito
comunali e da mia moglie la madre
naturale è esplosa
[Musica]
e la cosa più bella del mondo fatto
questo qui è il suo paradiso stare
appiccicato a un essere umano al caldo
per diventare il grinch e nella vita
reale come t a freddo forza mi ha detto
la faccia freddo appunto ma te piace il
natale no no va bene bellissima ma il
devastante stavolta a e gelido tu non
hai capito quant'è freddo
[Musica]
fermo lardini stai fermo
e un culo sulla pronto i ragazzi al
volante un uomo che è arrivata alla
frutta
sardi dentata
le ragazze allora siamo tutti pronti si
parte conosciuti
[Applauso]
ma vedi così si fa nulla vale un cazzo
ok ci siamo datemi nostre migliori
espressioni
scritto buon natale un cazzo tu non puoi
[Musica]
sono arrivati questo è il risultato
finale
quando lo aprite avete tutte queste
caselline vuote appunto da riempire e
potete infilarci minuti pare c'è potere
compresi i dolcetti mette inviarceli
piccoli regalini potete metterci dei
biglietti contento dei pensieri
penitenze quello che vi pare alla fine
come fanno sapere che la casagrande
quella del natale il resto anche
divertente passato un pochino random
almeno con se tenant e per quel caso in
via guardate ogni singola casella una
volta fatto questo chiudete c'è una
linguetta che togliete si sigilla il
calendario ea quel punto perché lui
questo è il nostro calendario
dell'ufficio non è l'unico che abbia
vuol dire che abbia preso un altro
sempre da riempire nel quale metteremo
tanti cioccolatini pensieri carini tipo
comodo di noi nipoti e lo regaleremo
stasera nostrana ma del suo compleanno
prima però di far vedere la sua reazione
io ancora una volta vi ringrazio nera
visto questo video grazie a caccia è
perché ormai è una partnership che
proprio avanti da tantissimo tempo se
anche voi volete acquistare il
calendario vi lasciamo tutti quanti link
che vi spiegano tutto quanto vi fanno
accedere al sito è tutto estremamente
facile e tutto ciò vi mando un bacio e
ci vediamo al prossimo in video
da notare come si festeggiano i
compleanni seri a casa oggi ci è andata
di lusso legambiente anche noi siamo
stati esonerati dalla terza classe
insieme azzardoso e posso mangiare in
una tavola da ricchi stavo aspettando
che arrivino i
lavori
a nanna abbiamo un regalo di compleanno
grazie siete dei soldi il calendario
dell'avvento
che bravi io la vigna si gian marco de
marco
enrico ricorda
valentina graziana poi ci stanno
alessandro che finita qui solamente a
parte gli auguri guardino
e mary che è la ragazza che lavora con
noi anzi
può salvare la vita e svoltare mi legano
alla nonna che anche questi
[Musica]
temi ma quanti più a chi ha ricevuto
stasera
e almeno in quanto male
[Musica]